straßenschlachten und plünderungen in
stuttgart hunderte randalierer
attackieren nach einer drogenkontrolle
die polizei und verwüsten geschäfte
immer mehr corona fälle im fleisch
betrieb dennoch bleiben dem kreis
gütersloh aber weitere drastische
einschränkungen erspart und messer
angriff mit drei toten im englischen
reading die polizei geht mittlerweile
von einem terroristischen hintergrund
aus
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg wird und ein herzliches
willkommen laut könig ist auch dabei für
den springer höher genannt
stuttgart hat eine beispiellose nacht
hinter sich polizei politik und bürger
sind entsetzt über die ausschreitungen
und die gewalt gegen polizisten
der innenminister spricht von einer nie
dagewesenen qualität hunderte
verwüsteten teile der innenstadt
bewarfen polizisten mit steinen und
flaschen
mehrere beamte wurden verletzt geschäfte
geplündert die lage seit
zwischenzeitlich völlig außer kontrolle
geraten
sandra susanka berichtet die bilder die
in den sozialen medien kursieren zeigen
die brutalität gegen die polizei
vergangene nacht randalieren bis zu 500
menschen in der stuttgarter innenstadt
corona bedingt sind die meisten klubs
noch geschlossen deshalb wird draußen
gefeiert
eine drogenkontrolle bei einem 17
jährigen soll der anfang der
auseinandersetzungen gewesen sein bei
dem 19 beamte verletzt wurden
mit diesem ganz normalen für uns
üblichen einschreiten haben sich sofort
zwei bis dreihundert anwesende personen
dort aus sag ich mal aus der partyszene
und freitags abends samstagabend szene
solidarisieren haben sofort die
polizeibeamten vor ort massiv
angegriffen mit steinen und
flaschenwürfen dutzend der gewalttätige
kleingruppen ziehen durch die innenstadt
erst nach mehreren stunden bekommt die
polizei die lage in den griff
24 personen werden festgenommen war
heute nachbarinnen nie dagewesene
dimension von offener gewalt gegen
polizeibeamte und massive
sachbeschädigungen bis hin zu
plünderungen in unserer städtischen
trauriger tag
die scheiben von 40 geschäften
eingeschlagen leben geplündert auch der
von airbus an der am morgen das ausmaß
der zerstörung sieht sind schockiert
eigentlich dass so was in stuttgart
passiert
und ja wir haben erst gedacht dass es
nur unsere filialen davon betroffen sind
und dann letztendlich sehe ich ja auch
der nachbar helmut uhr laden und andere
weitere filialen vom schuhladen bis euro
laden
schon seit wochen nehme die
aggressivität unter den feiernden zu so
die polizei
jetzt sollen deutlich mehr einsatzkräfte
für sicherheit sorgen
zweites großes thema heute der korona
ausbruch im kreis gütersloh 1300
infizierte sind es mittlerweile im
schlachtbetrieb turniers trotzdem will
ministerpräsident laschet keinen
flächendeckenden lockdown auch weil
bisher fast ausschließlich arbeiter aus
der fleisch verlegung betroffen sind und
nicht die übrige bevölkerung die kritik
an den zuständen bei turniers und in der
gesamten fleischindustrie wächst herr
khorram proteste von tierschützern vor
dem kreishaus in gütersloh
nrw-ministerpräsident laschet informiert
sich über die schwierigkeiten bei der
eindämmung der pandemie in den
vergangenen 24 stunden gab es in dem
unternehmen turniers einige hundert neue
infektionen alle mitarbeiter sind in
quarantäne
diese lage ist deshalb so schwierig weil
wir hier eine sehr dezentrale
unterbringung der mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter haben an 1300 standorten so
dass wir hier ein enormes pandemie
risiko haben im tennis werk in rheda
wiedenbrück hat sich das virus
explosionsartig verbreitet schuld daran
seien die zustände in der
fleischwirtschaft so experten turniers
hat bereits freiwillige verbesserungen
angekündigt aber mit der
fleischwirtschaft kann es keine
freiwilligen vereinbarung geben das muss
klare gesetzliche regelung geben die in
ganz deutschland gelten damit die
beschäftigten aus osteuropa die
quarantäne nicht verlassen und quer
durch mehrere länder in ihrer heimat
zurückreisen sollen dolmetscher erklären
dass sie den gesamten schutz durch das
deutsche gesundheitssystem erhalten oder
am abend die nachricht die firma
turniers will die kosten für corona
tests tragen für die gesamte bevölkerung
im kreis gütersloh
noch haben sich dort nur 16 menschen
außerhalb des unternehmens infiziert
daher gibt es im moment keinen lockdown
für den kreis lokale ausbrüche wie wir
bei turniers schlagen sich auch bei der
zahl der neu infizierten in deutschland
nieder
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich 490 menschen täglich neu
angesteckt vergangenen dienstag lag der
wert noch bei 220 großbritannien ist
entsetzt über eine messerattacke gestern
abend in der stadt redding in einem park
stach ein mann unvermittelt auf menschen
ein
drei sterben drei sind verletzt die
polizei geht von einem terroranschlag
aus
was genau den 25 jährigen vermutlich in
libyen trieb ist noch unklar
andreas stamm berichtet ein park im
herzen reddings spurensuche am tag
danach berichten zeugen von
traumatischen sie saßen im kreis tranken
etwas eine große gruppe acht bis zehn
leute er stürzte gegen den uhrzeigersinn
los erwischte den ersten ging weiter
stark auf den nächsten ein
so ging es weiter und weiter der
mutmaßliche täter kgs gestoppt und
festgenommen
durch schnelles mutiges eingreifen von
unbewaffneten polizisten vor ort er soll
aus libyen stammen noch in der nacht
wurde seine wohnung unweit des tatorts
durchsucht danach gingen die ermittler
von einem terroranschlag aus
bislang haben die ermittler nichts
finden können das annehmen lässt dass
noch jemand in den angriff verwickelt
sein könnte wir suchen keine weiteren
tatbeteiligten k s sei schon mal ins
visier der terror ermittler geraten
heißt es damals eingestuft als
ungefährlich die dritte messerattacke
mit terroristischem hintergrund in den
vergangenen sieben monaten die terror
warnstufe in großbritannien wird dennoch
nicht erhöht noch vieles zu motiv und
hintergrund der tat sei unklar
währenddessen konnten zwei der drei
verletzten das krankenhaus wieder
verlassen
mit einem paukenschlag wollte sich
donald trump im us-wahlkampf
zurückmelden
doch zu seiner mega veranstaltung in
tauscha oklahoma kamen deutlich weniger
menschen als erwartet viele plätze in
der halle blieben leer
was den präsidenten nicht vor
scharfe attacken abhielt bejubelt von
seinen anhängern denen corona mundschutz
mehrheitlich egal war
im at wissen ja es gab wortgefechte
zwischen demonstranten und tram fans von
denen waren einige sogar mit waffen
doch es blieb friedlich ungehindert
strömten die menschen in die halle
bekamen eine maske die dann kaum jemand
trug es kamen viele und doch so die
feuerwehr
nur 6200 ein drittel der hallenkapazität
trotz der angeblich eine million
anfragen offenbar reservierten tausende
trump gegner darunter viele jugendliche
karten ohne zu erscheinen doch trump
behauptet gewalttätige demonstranten
seien schuld unsere leute sind bei
weitem nicht so gewalttätig aber wenn
sie es wären wäre es ein schrecklicher
tag für die andere seite mit solchen
drohungen auch falschbehauptungen
mitunter rassistischen anspielungen war
die rede angefüllt eine viertelstunde
lang rechtfertigte der präsident dass er
bei einem anderen auftritt vorsichtig
eine rampe hinab gegangen war
er sei nicht krank könne sogar ein glas
wasser problemlos halten
kein wort dagegen zum mord an george
floyd dafür aber zu corona wenn man so
viel testet findet man eben mehr fälle
ich habe meinen leuten gesagt sie sollen
langsamer testen hinterher würde seine
sprecherin das als scherz bezeichnet
sogar für manchen in der halle war es
anstrengend oder auch donald trump hatte
sich seinem wahlkampfauftakt vermutlich
anders vorgestellt
fußball haben wir auch noch vor reiche
zweite bundesliga ja genau das was
positives für stuttgart denn da hat der
vfb stuttgart am vorletzten spieltag 6
zu 0 in nürnberg gewonnen und die fans
in stuttgart jubeln genau wie die profis
denn die schwaben haben die direkte
rückkehr in die bundesliga damit so gut
wie geschafft weil der hsv in letzter
minute mit 1 2 in heidenheim verloren
hat die heidenheimer sind am letzten
spieltag in bielefeld zu gast der hsv
muss also auf schützenhilfe durch den
zweitligameister hoffen um wenigstens
noch den relegationsplatz erreichen zu
können
und dabei ein ende steht karlsruhe auf
dem relegationsplatz richtung dritte
liga kann aber nach dem 3 3 gegen
bielefeld den 1 fc nürnberg am kommenden
sonntag noch überholen
wiesbaden verliert in darmstadt dynamo
dresden gewinnt in sandhausen beide
haben wegen ihrer schlechten
tordifferenz kaum noch chancen den
direkten abstieg zu vermeiden
beim abschlussturnier der basketball
bundesliga in münchen haben die
halbfinals begonnen heute das
schwaben-derby ludwigsburg gegen ulm ein
hinspiel mit ungewohnten ergebnis holen
in den schwarzen trikots und ludwigsburg
liefern sich ein extrem spannendes
erstes halbfinale um die deutsche
meisterschaft immer wieder kann sich
eine der mannschaften etwas absetzen
aber nie entscheidend
die ludwigsburger die meister bayern
münchen ausgeschaltet hatten mit der
etwas besseren ersten hälfte und einer
knappen führung zur pause
danach dann bessere ulmer sie sind
ohnehin die überraschung bislang bei
diesem final turnier ein spezialfall
dann am ende normalerweise ist ein
unentschieden beim basketball
ausgeschlossen weil hier aber die
ergebnisse aus hin und rückspiel addiert
werden bleibt es heute beim 71 zu 71 die
spannung also bleibt rückspiel am
dienstag wunderbar vielen dank
wettermäßig beginnt die neue woche sehr
unterschiedlich im osten und süden viele
wolken und einzelne schauer sonst
überwiegend sonnig bei 19 bis 26 grad
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse morgen begrüßt sie hier petra
gerster wir wünschen ihnen noch einen
entspannten sonntag abend sagen tschüss
und empfehlen jetzt theo koll und berlin
direkt